hey what's up rotten tomatoes and them
thank y'all so much for uh the beautiful
Award of winning best reviewed Sports
film of
2023 big shout out to Amazon for putting
up that money uh big shout out to all
the cast and the crew especially that
Marin Waynes with that one scene that
really made the
movie uh shout out to all the cast hello
Davis Chris Tucker um Ben Affleck the
amazing director Matt Damon the direct
the guys directors producers they just
everybody did such a fabulous job but
most of all thank you to the critics man
uh we always appreciate your opinions
and uh luckily we was on the right side
of this one um I've been on the wrong
side a lot but it's nice to be on the
right side um and also most of all to
the fans you know cuz without y'all none
of us would be doing this air
peace